j'ai un truc inavouables à vous dire et
vous avez tous avoir un truc qui n'avoue
à bien nous raconter ici vous le dis moi
j'ai mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
j'ai pleuré devant le le grand frère cet
après midi je n'étais pas bien je sais
plus le grand frère j'ai versé de ma
famille qui se retrouve elle s'était pas
bien j'en ai chialé les gars ça et avec
tout ça on aime ça
tout ça est ce que vous avez quelque
chose d'inavouable à dire aux
téléspectateurs ce soir là tout de suite
maintenant oui mais bon on repasse à
saluer oui en fait quand j'étais petit
ça s'est passé plutôt à mes parents je
suis partie au commissariat en fait
parce que j'étais dans un centre
commercial est en fête avec un copain on
avait volé et c'était pas bien et je
veux pas tu dors j'avais dit à mes
parents c'était moi qui avait volé donc
c'est tout tout est retombé sur mon pote
il s'est pris des gifs par tout le monde
est en fait j'avais volé un truc
complètement ridicule et je tiens à le
dire ce singe equal orange bien quoi en
fait j'étais fan de poisson rouge et
j'ai volé des hameçons pour pêcher non
c'est une belle histoire donc c'était la
dernière fois vous aviez volet d'accord
battre erika moulet est avec nous s'il
avoue abl le problème c'est que j'avais
pas 13 ans c'est la dernière deux mois
j'ai volé des hameçons est-ce que c'est
à dire 2 il ya trois mois j'étais tout
seul donc personne c'est ouais
j'étais à montmartre et j'ai fait un
resto basket mais tout seul c'est à dire
au total on va dire voilà 35 ans c'est
quoi les mecs amène l'addition je me
suis dit je me fais un cap ou pas moi
même et je me suis dit est ce que je
suis capable d'en sortir par la porte
wide et de parole et de ne pas payer à
ma jeune il était serein
et je pense à tous les restaurateurs qui
font leur métier qui ont des problèmes
avec la tva et elle est la rivale
connais pas c'est moche caca boudin
tu veux que je te dise moi j'ai été
serveur et quand on est serveur comme
quelqu'un se barrer sans payer ses
serveurs qui doit payer
exactement et je vais faire non c'est à
vous que je vais donner l'oseille
qu'elle adorait dû donner la fois
quelque chose d'inavouable à part votre
personne alors moi tu as quelques années
quand c'était sorti le week end quand on
sortait que les copains on se mettait
vraiment à y avait une bande de décodage
mathieu il ya des gens courageux
wilfried walter il y avait beaucoup et
trop mais ça m'est déjà arrivé
maintenant on habitait au premier étage
mais l'arrivée de rester dans l'escalier
toute la nuit par monter le premier
alors c'est un soir je rentre et je vois
bien un peu comme vous que je me couche
et ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne quand
elle tourne et là vous avez eu la pépie
prix non là je vomis tout nouveau
meeting sur lui dans le lit chez moi et
j'étais tellement mal que je suis resté
dedans me suis rendormi de données dans
le monde jusqu'au lendemain
le lendemain tu très bientôt changer les
draps le matelas imbibé ya pas d'allez
donc c'est dégueulasse qu'on a un mois
dans ta chambre
ah ouais donc il fallait changer le lit
mais je n'avais pas d'argent tiens
d'ailleurs se répète mon coup de gueule
le prix des leaders mais beau serge
c'est bon c'est bon merci par avance
y'a quand même quelqu'un juste deux
minutes mené la venelle à venir il ya
quand même quelques uns aussi qu'
apparemment il ya vovk il ya sophie
gravaud mis sur la tête aussi
[Musique]
il ya vraiment quelque chose
d'inavouable c'est tellement un fonds
bout j'aimerais un jour je suis rentré
sans quelqu'un sans me suis dépêché
quelqu'un alors qu'il va pas on vous
dira alors il sait qu on dise oh yeah
quoi dans les loges
si vous avez fait quand il n'aura
s'échanger j'ai regarder ses fesses non
la doua que les bêtes ainsi à l'art déco
sont pas du tout la vraie question que
tout est devant nous
pékin va regarder derrière voyez que ça
la vraie question que tout le monde se
pose comment son effet ce très joli
alors là on n'est pas d'accord y'a pas
d'exploit elle les montre à tout le
monde
[Rires]
jusqu'à la halle est quelque chose qui
n'a bouclé sauf à les y voilà
c'est dégueulasse c'est fois bah vous
voilà c'est dur a avoué j'ai un plaisir
coupable en fait quand vous ronger les
ongles des pieds
non sans blague alors je fais
systématiquement je vous rassure j'adore
le turini je vous jure que c'est vrai la
dernière fois il a sorti une boucle il
était au bowling je ne crois pas de
boulot est fait comme ça il a sorti d'un
brouillard
allez y en a deux cas il appert cela sur
le continent et d'ailleurs il y en a un
gardien au canada c'est une ligue 1 je
vais très très discrètement
non mais c'est vrai mais toujours le
voyage et un mouchoir non non j'ai un
mouchoir et tout ce dont j'ai la passion
des vitres et de je vis très doux serrer
la main alors rien à lui d'ailleurs il
est très propre
heureusement parce que celui-ci devait
sortir missy sortait les crocs de zen
lui c'est la comète de halley déconner
tu faisais ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il ya tout le système solaire dans son
élan gilbert des bâtiments c'est pas
grave ça on aura on aura votre votre
truc qui d'avoir un sens je voulais je
vous laisse pour la fin et doha votre
votre truc qui n'a voit bien quand même
acquéreur qui vient de tomber
un cadreur vient de tomber alors oui
laure bonsoir c'est une anecdote vrai
lors d'un entretien d'embauché j'avais
extrêmement extrêmement envie de faire
pipi et je me suis uriné dessus juste
dans l'entretien nouveau j'avais des
collants ça faisait des bulles de piste
étaient arrivés j'espère pas les pipis
on dirait une chanson de mylène farmer
[Musique]
c'est
est ce qui est génial c'est que pendant
l'entretien d'embauché
le patron j'étais jeune j'avais 20 ans
mais disais c'est pas possible je suis
vraiment navré jeune fille parce qu'il
ya une odeur dans mon bureau vraiment je
suis désolé parce que de ménage n'a pas
été fait le mec a ouvert les fenêtres
c'est juste moi qui a été vraiment et
tout un pipi au parec aussi dans ce même
bureau et un gars qui a vomi jean luc
lemoine l'apartheid l'anc élégance cent
fois ce n'est pas un tour et histoire
alors oui je n'en voyais en a deux je
suis comme vous j'ai pleuré devant
pascal le grand frère mais il était
devant moi il m'a tapée donc c'était
annoncé c'est un truc qu'on te mais
j'étais tout petit jeu si je veux
demander pardon à ma famille en fait on
était à l'hôtel avec ma famille à
l'époque il y avait pas de télé dans
tout dans toutes les chambres
il y avait des salons de thé de télé
dans les hôtels et donc qu'on descend
avec ma famille après manger pour aller
au salon de télé et on est rentrés tous
ont été concentrées sur on est rentrés
gpt pt tout le monde s'est retournée
famille était très gênée on ne peut pas
dire tous tous
alors je vais vous dire aujourd'hui que
c'est tout à votre honneur vous aussi
d'avouer parce que ce comme on lit paix
avouée à moitié pardonnée bravo là
c'est tout à votre honneur
vraiment bravo aujourd'hui qui je suis
fier de sa monnaie mais vraiment bravo